hey there friends what up so in case you
didn't know this I teach live stream po
lessons over on a platform called
crowdcast and uh I'm in the middle of
teaching a beginner unit right now so I
thought that I would go ahead and share
with you one of the lessons that we have
uh gone through in the course of this
class uh this lesson is on driving
Styles and timing and Direction and I'm
hoping that you find something in there
that appeals to you Drex here from Drex
Factor po sharing with you the love po
spinning and flowarts to benefit your
body and brain and today I'm also
sharing with you another resource that I
make available out there for people
wanting to spin po before I show it to
you though I want to give a quick shout
out to the Friends of the channel big
thanks to dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys juggling calling pyate
light toys spinballs and Ultra poy for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these awesome companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links down in the description of
this video and special thanks to the
non-b buus friend of the channel Becca
Becken thank you so very much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission cool so a little bit of
background to start us off here about a
year and a half ago I started teaching
live stream lessons on crowdcast as a
way to test out some material that I was
working on for teaching beginners how to
spend Po and specifically po dance I
have just started up a new six- week
unit where I am teaching those very
things and I want to give you all a
taste of what exactly it's like taking
these classes from me so I went ahead
and edited together an excerpt of our
first class talking about driving Styles
and timing and direction to share with
all of you if you'd like to check out
the uh full course online you can do
that over at crowdcast doio drexfactor
pooy but for right now check out the
lesson I hope you like it uh we're going
to start off in wall plane here and I'm
going to introduce you to something
called a driving Style a driving style
is defined by how much energy we put
into the poy as our hand is moving
around so the most basic kind of driving
style there is is what we would call an
extension that is as your hand is
working its way around clockwise and
wall plane you can get the poy to spin
in one giant circle with it your poy
becomes an extension of your arm as
you're doing this here hence extension
so let's try playing around with some
different driving Styles then um rather
than doing the extension and making sure
that the PO has enough energy to go over
our hand as our hand is going over our
head we can instead do a pendulum let's
say have our hand and Our poise swing
together as one big unit going back and
forth across our body like so and with
that in mind now we can also play play
around with the idea of taking it over
top so it's almost like you're dabbing
with a paintbrush on either side of your
body so now let's put those two pieces
together shall we we got the piece where
it's SW excuse me it'll be the other way
around because I'm mirroring you you
swing from
your right shoulder to your left
shoulder and then you take it up and
over back over to your right so you'll
note our hand is still doing this big
circle going around clockwise but our
AIM now is to make sure that we get the
POI poking straight out to the side on
either end but it does not go over our
hand cool so we now know two driving
Styles we know how to do
extensions and we know how to do
pendulums I want you to practice going
back and forth between them try doing
one two three extensions and
one 2
three pendulums one two three extensions
and
one
two three pendulums see how much energy
you have to put into the PO in order to
perform the extension and how much
energy you have to take away in order to
do the pendulum go ahead and put down
the PO for a second we're going to give
the poy a little bit of a rest and we're
going to talk about the four timing and
Direction modes so timing and Direction
Just refers to how we think about two
objects moving around a third object in
space how they can move in directions
related to each other and how they can
move phase related to each other there
are only two directions it's either both
of those objects are going around the
same
direction or they're going around in
opposite directions technically speaking
there's an infinite number of phasings
but we really only use two together time
and split time so our four timing and
Direction mode are as follows we can do
together same we also have together
opposites where we spread our arms out
draw them up cross them and then bring
them back together down at the bottom
here but the real thing that we got that
we want to do here in uh in wheel plane
is this split times same direction this
is going to feel a lot like you're doing
the crawl stroke as far as I'm concerned
what each arm is doing here is like I'm
waving it from top to bottom and back
again like this is really the pattern
that I'm doing with my hands I just
happen to be turning my upper body back
and forth as I'm doing that in order to
turn that into circles and our final
timing and Direction mode takes us back
to wall plane and that is going to
involve
um taking our hands apart on our Center
Line and bringing them together to the
side they come apart on our Center Line
come back together to the side uh the
the ponic device that I've seen for this
is to snap your fingers when one hand is
top and one hand is bottom clap them
together to the side snap your fingers
apart clap them to the side snap top and
bottom clap them to the side snap top
and bottom clap them to the side and it
may not be clear from seeing this on
video but once again this is one of
those places where this is the actual
arm motion that I'm doing here if I
don't move my upper body around I'm just
swiping my hands past each other when I
do move my upper body though turns them
into circles notice that every time I
bring my hands to the side one of my
shoulders is pointing towards the camera
hey do you remember that exercise that
we did earlier getting down all of our
driving Styles hey hey what if we do all
that with all these different timing and
Direction modes what about that so let's
say for the sake of argument that we
wanted to have our po go around in
pendulums and together same
clockwise again we want to do three
reps
2 1 and then three extensions 3
2 one all right and then we got to do
the entire thing with together opposite
so um
we do these
pendulums and then we do our
extensions and then of
course we have the fun job of doing all
of
this swimming here in wheel
plane I do my pendulums which means that
I want to here here's going to be the
trick is that you're going to be spin
you're going to be swimming very very
very
slowly and then you're going to speed up
how fast you're swimming to do your
extensions and then of course our final
timing and Direction mode is to play
around with split time
opposites we want to do our
pendulums we want to do our
extensions it's going to feel like doing
double Dutch jump roping as I'm waiting
for people to chime in on the keyboards
if they need help or clarification or
anything uh if indeed I went ahead and
posted this uh lesson online and you are
enjoying the lesson uh you can join us
for the rest of the uh the the class
unit the six week unit uh over at
crowdcast
doio direct Factor poy thank you all for
tuning in have yourselves a great week
and I will see you next Tuesday so if
you're curious and you'd like to check
out the rest of the unit including the
one driving style that I edited out of
this excerpt you can do that by signing
up for the class over at crowdcast doio
drexfactor pooy I will include a link to
it down in the
[Music]
description big thanks to my supporters
on patreon for supporting the channel
cuz without them I would not be able to
put this awesome excerpt out there for
all of you uh in particular I'd love to
give a shout out to my flow patrons who
are listed on screen right now if you
like the work that I do and you would
like to sign up to support it you can do
so over on patreon at
patreon.com drexfactor po there's a
whole host of awesome rewards that are
available there but even better than
that that helps give me the means that I
need to keep on producing videos for The
Wider world so check that out please and
thank you and if you don't have the
means to sign up for the course that's
fine the beta version of the material
that I'm covering was actually in that
whole series that I did during
quarantine called learn how to spin poy
during the covid-19 lockdown I'll go
ahead and link to it down in the
description as well as up here on screen
thanks so much for watching make sure to
get out and flow today and I'll see you
with a new video real soon and hopefully
I'll see you in one of my live stream
classes too take care now peace